[Music]
i remember i was in high school
and i was sweating bullets because i was
afraid i didn't know
who to talk to about college i didn't
know
who to connect with because my my major
in college right now is business
and always heard throughout high school
that you need to have networking you
need to network
with certain people when you're in
business i was scared of networking
because
i didn't know when to where to start who
to talk to where to begin
but through applying through the nevada
promise scholarship
they gave me a mentor my mentor name is
hilary boutrico
and i can say that if it wasn't for her
i wouldn't be speaking to you today
if it wasn't for her i wouldn't have a
college experience like i did if it
wasn't for her i wouldn't have the
resources that she
provided for me for being my mentor
because she has
allowed me into her inner circle she has
provided me with the resources as i
said she has led me into her inner
circle to meet
new people and clients that can help me
along my journey